all right joining us now with reaction
on the ground in South Carolina tonight
Fox Nation hosts Nancy Grace who has
been tracking this trial from the very
beginning joining us tonight from South
Carolina it wasn't just South Carolina
Nancy it was the entire country riveted
by this case and leading up to the jury
being handed this case earlier tonight I
will tell you that there was a lot of
trepidation concern and worry that the
prominence of this family the name the
connections might play a role and might
sway one juror to perhaps hang this uh
this verdict that didn't happen three
hours that's almost a record
yes you're right that is almost a record
and it was across the country can I tell
you Sean everywhere I went here and
we've been here throughout the trial
whether it's at the Holiday Inn or the
sandwich shop or the fish fryer here at
the courthouse or in front of the
Methodist Church people come up to me
and say he's going to get off isn't he
he's going to get off because he is a
Murdoch that's the king and the queen of
Colleton County and I've got to tell you
when I saw Alex Murdoch on that stand
crying like that
I didn't feel pity because I knew he
murdered his wife and his son can I ask
you a question think about it there was
his wife and his son lying there on the
floor of a dog kennel their bodies
riddled with bullets and within minutes
he was trying to get with a lawyer now
if that was my son John David or my
daughter Lucy that would be the last
thing on my mind and even when he called
9-1-1 Sean he knew to lie about the
critical moment of time three or four
minutes when we know the murders
occurred based on cell phone records he
knew to lie about that critical juncture
of time who else would know when the
murders occurred other than the Killer
let me ask you this Nancy because it
seems like when he was on tape with the
police officers lying and saying he was
not near the kennel and then it was
months later that they got they finally
were able to get into his son's cell
phone and there was audio placing him in
the kennel just moments before the
murders took place was that the key
moment was that the moment where the the
jury got to say wait a minute all these
lies that he's telling he he lied to us
in this trial
that in my mind was the moment you know
how in every case there's that critical
moment in orenthal James Simpson O.J
Simpson it was when he faked not being
able to put that glove on that was the
Turning moment in this video Sean he is
out there at the kennels of his hunting
lodge they own three homes is that the
kennels of the hunting lodge with son
Paul wife Maggie and they're trying to
get a video of her friend's dog to send
to a lady vet and they couldn't make the
dog be still and Paul is taking this
video little did Alex Murdoch know that
at the very end of that video his voice
is caught in the background saying
something like that's not a chicken
that's a guinea because one of the dogs
is chasing a bird they caught his voice
he had no idea he was caught and for 20
plus months he lied through his teeth
including that night when he was asked
where were you he could have easily said
I was just with my my wife I was with
Paula at the kennel and then I went to
go see my mom but he lied he lied
because he knew he would be placing
himself at the scene of the crime at the
time of the murder when they unlocked
that phone and they had to use the
Secret Service by the way to get that
phone unlocked they heard the video many
witnesses identified his voice and
finally he said hey uh you know what
that was me that was the moment yeah
agreed Nancy uh one thing maybe people
don't know about you I certainly do
we've known each other a long time you
have been a powerful victims advocate
for many many years thank you for
joining us and and giving us your
insight into the case we really
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else